[Music]
on this Monday night reaching for the
Stars your mission specialist Jeremy
Hansen
the first Canadian to be part of a new
frontier the Revival of NASA's missions
to the Moon
Donald Trump travels to New York to turn
himself in what's next for the former
U.S president
Canadians enforcing sanctions on North
Korea we want to train as we fight so
that we're prepared for anything an
inside look at their training Mission
preparing for intercepts in the sky
Canadians coerced evidence the Chinese
government uses threats intimidation and
blackmail to pressure Chinese Canadians
and one on one with the Canadian
astronaut headed to the Moon you'll be
the only Canadian parent who can say to
your kids I love you to the moon and
back and actually prove it
what the lunar Mission means to this
father of three
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin tonight with a first for Canada
the Ontario man who is going to the moon
and back his name is Jeremy Hansen there
he is on the right he's been chosen as
one of four crew members on Artemis 2
the next mission to the Moon he's 47
raised on a farm and he's a former
fighter pilot who is trained for this
for years now he's the only Canadian who
is part of this Elite group set to
launch NASA's first crude mission to the
Moon in more than 50 years joining him
will be the first woman and the first
African-American astronaut to go on a
lunar Mission they won't land on the
moon that's still to come this mission
is a critical test Mike Armstrong has
our top story tonight your mission
specialist Jeremy Hansen
it's not a quality you associate with
being an astronaut but Jeremy Hansen's
patience is paying off it's been close
to 14 years since Hanson was picked as
an astronaut by the Canadian space
agency he's watched dozens and dozens of
NASA colleagues go off on missions well
after all the waiting he called this day
glorious we are going to the Moon
together let's go
foreign
further than any humans have been in
more than five decades it will fly 400
000 kilometers to the moon fly around it
and return to Earth the trip will last
about 10 days only Apollo Astronauts
between 1968 and 1972 have gone far
enough out to see the entire Earth now a
Canadian
is going to be part of the very next
people to see the first non-american to
do it it's a big deal it's really
important that astronauts are
comfortable in a water environment
Hanson was raised on a farm outside
London Ontario and says he doesn't
remember ever not wanting to be an
astronaut he attended Royal Military
College in Kingston became a fighter
pilot based in Cold Lake Alberta Bravo
One set and eventually pursued his
ultimate goal nine o'clockwise three set
is an exceptionally composed person he's
a good communicator he's considered by
many as a mentor to the new astronauts
that have come in so I mean this is this
is an incredible person
now the Artemis 2 mission will test the
spacecraft for an eventual trip back and
a landing on the moon well Canada's seat
on this next mission comes as part of a
deal with NASA Canada is contributing a
lunar rover to explore the moon and a
canadarm 3 that will help build a lunar
Outpost Gateway we'll be building a
small space station that will be in
orbit around the Moon where astronauts
can live and work and prepare for future
destinations the plan is to eventually
use the moon and Gateway as a stepping
stone on a trip to Mars but there are
other missions in the meantime Canada
has seats on two more missions to the
International Space Station and when
it's built Canadian will eventually
visit Gateway as well
Mike Armstrong Global News Saint Joubert
Quebec
a little later I'll talk to Jeremy
Hansen about when he started dreaming
about going to the Moon and what he says
about the importance of teamwork
Global News has uncovered evidence and
examples of how the Chinese Communist
party is coercing some Chinese Canadians
to spy on others in their Community here
in Canada victims say Chinese police
treat their family members back in China
as hostages blackmailing them and
threatening their safety Jeff simple
reports
whenever there's a protest in Ontario
against the Chinese government's human
rights abuses his is a familiar face
words are not enough just it's time to
take action as well toti is a uighur
Canadian his mostly Muslim ethnic group
is persecuted in China he escaped the
country three decades ago back in
January Toady was campaigning ahead of a
vote by the federal government to accept
ten thousand uyghur refugees and one
morning his phone rang
it was the Chinese police Toady recorded
the phone call and played it back for us
the Chinese police officer said he was
calling with news about toady's family
in China his mother and sisters whom
Toady hadn't heard from in a few years
were dead his sisters were in their 40s
the officer claimed they died from
Strokes the officer said toady's Uncle
also suffered a stroke but survived and
was in hospital then they put his uncle
on the phone
his uncle confirmed the other family
members were dead his wife is so weak
and it was a warning sign basically
given me the message that if you
continue and only the cousin you have
could share the same fate
unless you stop here in Ottawa toti says
he's been followed his activities
monitored by a network of spies erkin
kerban says Beijing tried to coerce him
into spying
they thought they had recruited me he
says the Montreal truck driver came to
Canada from China 20 years ago but in
2013 he went back for a visit
my mother to see his 85 year old mother
who was sick once he arrived he was
summoned for questioning by Chinese
police
the police officer took my Canadian
passport threw it on the floor and
stepped on it Corban says police knew
kurdban had attended uyghur rights
protests in Canada they said if he
cooperated they would treat him and his
family well and allow him to see his
mother
I asked them what do you want from me
they said you have to monitor and inform
us on activities in Canada he says
police were particularly interested in
several Canadian activists including
mahmet toti
they introduced me to my Handler and
said he would be in touch he says within
one week I started receiving phone calls
from him I was angry this Chinese
torontonian came to Canada in 2011 were
protecting his identity because he has
family in China until recently his wife
and daughter were there too he says they
were visited by Chinese police and told
to deliver a message you get a message
from your wife yeah and they're asking
you basically to to spy on your own
Community yes she was crying the first
time she was crying about that yeah she
feels so scared he says the Chinese
police threatened to repossess their
house in China unless he spied on his
Toronto landlord pro-democracy activist
Sheng shui I was
I was very very very shocking
because
when he lived downstairs you know we
don't even have
one door has locked shway strongly
suspects she's been spied on by others
in the community for years she says
she's reported harassment and
surveillance to police and government
officials with no result I have been
waiting for
the government and the community and the
media realize how how bad the Chinese
infantry in Canada Corban says he gave
Chinese authorities false and irrelevant
information and after six months they
stopped calling but he says many of his
own community members now view him with
suspicion anyone with family members
still in China could potentially be
coerced intimidation threat harassment
hijacking your family members and
pushing you
to live under the Chinese Shadow even
you are in free country they're far from
China but still in beijing's sites Jeff
sample Global News
Ottawa
tomorrow we'll hear firsthand accounts
from people who say they've been
targeted here in Canada for speaking out
against the Chinese governments
in Calgary today at least three people
were stabbed in the city's downtown in
the middle of the afternoon police say
the suspect was tracked and arrested
about 30 minutes after the attacks the
suspect is believed to be connected to
the stabbings and a robbery one of the
victims was taken to hospital with what
First Responders are calling traumatic
injuries and in BC an attack on a man on
a Transit bus over the weekend is being
treated as terrorism Abdul kawam was
charged originally with attempted murder
after allegedly slashing another man's
throat on a bus in Surrey on Saturday
our CMP National Security Police took
over the investigation after the suspect
made what police call several concerning
comments prosecutors have now added four
counts of terrorism and alleged the
attacks were carried out for the
so-called Islamic State a second person
was hurt in the incident both victims
are recovering
in New York City former president Donald
Trump is back at Trump Tower tonight
expected to turn himself in tomorrow to
be arraigned on criminal charges it's
related to a hush money payment made to
an adult film star Trump is the first
former U.S president in history to be
charged with a crime Jackson prosco is
in Manhattan tonight following
developments
as Donald Trump left his Florida home
crowds of supporters lined the highway
to the airport where the former
president boarded his private jet
and set off for a date with the justice
system arriving in New York he was
whisked to his luxury Penthouse at Trump
Tower for a night overlooking a city on
edge over what could happen while there
may be some rabble Rouses
thinking about coming to our city
tomorrow a message is clear and simple
control yourselves
Trump supporters are vowing to protest
35 000 New York police officers are on
standby it's in lower Manhattan where
history will unfold Tuesday where
reporters from around the world have
come to witness the first ever
arraignment of a former American
president hopefully this will be is is
painless and classy as possible for a
situation like this after he surrenders
Trump will be fingerprinted photographed
and appear before a judge but he's no
ordinary defendant he's already posting
online attacks on New York's attorney
general and the judge assigned to the
case despite all the noise
um there's no evidence uh suggesting
that this is a political prosecution
there's no evidence suggesting that
there are other people who committed
similar offenses that Manhattan
prosecutors decided not to prosecute
Jackson what are we expecting to see and
hear from the arraignment tomorrow
well Donna a lot of those details are
still being worked out at the last
minute here including whether or not a
camera might be allowed in the courtroom
its former president Trump though who is
at risk of not being able to say much
that's because of his ongoing comments
about both the district attorney and the
judge there's real risk that he has
slapped with some sort of gag order and
Donna that would prevent him from
discussing the trial unless he wants to
face severe criminal penalties in the
courts all right lots to come Jackson
prosco in Manhattan tonight thanks
enforcing North Korean sanctions coming
up the training Mission preparing
Canadian Forces for possible intercepts
in the sky
a team from the Canadian Armed Forces is
preparing for deployment as part of a
multinational effort to monitor
sanctions on North Korea Global News was
given access to the training Mission as
the team prepares for potential
intercepts in the sky Nita Garcia
reports
Lieutenant Colonel Don jamond is taking
the next steps in preparing his crew for
what they may face overseas it's
tailored to the mission that we're going
to go do it's uh it's an important piece
of our preparation
it's important for all of our crews to
do this training before we go away on
other exercises or operations in which
there's a chance on air forces from
around the world may intercept Festival
of our way
taking off from the Basin Comox BC the
Canadian Armed Forces says exercises
like this range from four to six hours
off BC's West Coast we're doing some
interception practice so just simulating
that as if we were being intercepted by
a fighter aircraft
the mission they're training for is
Operation neon Canada's contribution to
the monitoring of un sanctions designed
to deter North Korea from its weapons of
mass destruction programs since recent
operations there's been there's been
some intercepts like that it's valuable
training in November the Royal Canadian
Air Force told Global News Chinese
military jets intercepted one of its
surveillance planes during a recent
operation neon Mission this training
preparing the crew for similar scenarios
basically just fly alongside the uh our
aircraft just to show us that they're
defending their territory
Aurora crew is actually communicating
directly with the pilot in the
intercepting Alpha jet do dating its
next move we're basically just talking
to the uh to the Jet Pilot just
directing them to go through the
different sets uh different types of uh
intercept from different angles having
the pilots know the position of the
aircraft is very important and this is a
great chance for us to practice that a
real intercept would be much less
predictable overseas you know we don't
want anything to come as a big surprise
we want to train as we fight so that
we're prepared for anything
it's not every day that we get to see
something like that so this is pretty
unique while this level of training is
new the planes they're flying May soon
be as well as this crew was in the air
last week the federal government
announced it's moved closer to a
possible acquisition of Boeing Poseidon
aircraft to replace these aging auroras
nitugarcha Global News
Beijing balloon ahead new reports on
what the Chinese object was up to while
in North American airspace
there are reports that Chinese spy
balloon which flew through Canada and
into the United States in February
gathered intelligence from sensitive
American Military sites and was able to
transmit information back to Beijing NBC
News quoting senior U.S officials
reports the High Altitude balloon passed
over some sites multiple times and was
capable of beaming back information in
real time it's believed the intelligence
came mostly from electronic signals
which can be picked up from weapon
systems at the time the U.S played down
the impact on National Security the
balloon spent a week flying over the U.S
and Canada before it was shot down by
American fighter jets off the Atlantic
coast on President Joe Biden's orders
the U.S has since recovered and analyzed
debris and says intelligence collected
has limited value Beijing claims it was
an Airship that accidentally straight
off course not a government spy balloon
a Lebanese Canadian academic went on
trial In Absentia in France today Hassan
diab is facing charges related to a
bombing outside of Paris synagogue over
40 years ago diab is the lone suspect in
the attack which killed four people and
wounded dozens he's accused of planting
a bomb in October of 1980 outside the
synagogue where 320 worshipers had
gathered Canada authorized diab's
extradition to France in 2014 he spent
three years in prison but was free due
to a lack of evidence and returned to
Canada the French court of appeal later
ruled he must stand trial the
69-year-old denies any involvement in
the attack
next Canada's Jeremy Hansen talks to me
about how a treehouse and teamwork
prepared him for his upcoming mission to
the Moon
[Music]
a Canadian is going to the Moon with our
International partnership and it is
glorious
well you don't get picked for a job like
that unless you've trained for years and
are at the top of your game Canadian
astronaut Jeremy Hansen is he is part of
the Artemis II crew that will fly around
the Moon next year the first Canadian to
ever do so
Jeremy Hansen joins me now from Houston
Jeremy what a treat to speak with you
you know I know part of a job
requirement is to remain cool calm and
collected at all times but how are you
feeling today
yeah maybe not completely calm or a
collected uh pretty extraordinary day
for myself as a Canadian for my family
but most importantly I hope for
Canadians I really hope they feel the
pride that I felt today standing with my
American colleagues setting this big
goal going back to the moon this goal
around collaborations very meaningful
for me it was very meaningful to see our
partners highlight Canada and really
lift us up and highlight what our
amazing country has done to put us in
this position to send a human around the
Moon Jeremy I grew up on a farm like you
and I remember often looking up at the
Moon especially on summer nights in
Wonder but never thinking I was going to
go there did you have that dream as a
kid
I did I I was really interested in
aviation and I was thumbing through
encyclopedia and I for airplanes and I
came across uh Neil Armstrong and I saw
a picture of a human standing on the
moon I was young and it made it I can
still see the image of that page burnt
in my mind it really made an impression
on me I never looked at the moon the
same way right away I turned my tree
house into a rocket ship I had gauges
and dials and circuit breakers for
switches whatever I could find around
the farm and I was exploring space and I
just didn't know that that would be a
long shot people told me that it was
possible I was pretty lucky to be lifted
up and mentored along the way that's
terrific I know you trained as a fighter
pilot you graduated from Astronaut
candidate training in 2011. you're the
first Canadian to lead NASA's Astronaut
training program what part of that vast
amount of work that you've done over the
years has best prepared you for this
Mission oh I think it's the diversity of
all those skills but probably the most
important one and we talk about it a lot
in the core I talk about it with youth
it's really important is
um teamwork it's got to be teamwork you
know you don't go to space alone and you
have to be very very intentional about
just continuing to evolve yourself with
respect to how you communicate with
others how you lift others up how you
support them having empathy this
actually turns out to be more important
for how much you can get done even more
important than the technical that's
interesting why does this test mission
to fly around the Moon matter so much
well you know Artemis 2 mission is you
know a next step to sending Humanity
back to the Moon in a sustainable way
going there to stay
um learning more about the moon
preparing us to go on to Mars so this is
just one more step
um so it matters it's important because
it sets us up for the success of the
future but more important for for me the
way I look at this this is a tremendous
symbol for Canadians for them to just
look and realize wow we can do
incredible things when we set big goals
and we collaborate globally sometimes I
think as Canadians we we keep ourselves
a little bit small and I've traveled all
across our country I've seen our space
industry talked to our scientists our
Engineers our youth I see it we're
brilliant and right now we're being
lifted up and showcased that we bring
real value to the globe and I love that
that I think for me will be the most
important story of Artemis 2. Jeremy it
struck me today that you'll be the only
Canadian parents who can say to your
kids I love you to the moon and back and
actually prove it
I saw that before and I used to say that
a lot it's on the wall of my daughter's
bedroom and uh so you're right it'll be
very meaningful for us as a family oh
terrific thank you so much Jeremy Hansen
yeah thank you
what an accomplished thoughtful and
down-to-earth guy that is global
national for this Monday I'm Donna
Friesen a little shout out to the town
where Jeremy Hansen went to high school
Ingersoll Ontario is tonight's here in
Canada please email your Canada to
viewers at globalnational.com and thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
thank you